خصم الامس حليف اليوم عباره قد تختصر
المشهد السياسي وربما الجغرافي المقبل على
الشمال السوري بعد ان كان الاسد صوره
الديكتاتور الاكبر في نظر الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بات مشروع تجاوز الخلافات
مطروحا اليوم على طاوله الحوار بواسطه
روسيه
[تصفيق]
اردوغان الذي ذهب الى حد اقتراح قمه
ثلاثيه لتسريع المسار الدبلوماسي مع دمشق
اثناء زياره الرئيس التركي لتركمانستان
ولقائه مع بوتين بدر الاول باقتراح سلسله
اجتماعات لحل عقده الخلافات بين انقره
ودمشق والتي تجاوز عمرها العقد من الزمن
اقترحت في اتصال
على مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات اولا ثم على
مستوى وزراء الدفاع ثم وزراء الخارجيه ثم
القاده
مبادره اردوغان ترافقت بشروط اولها
الوساطه الروسيه مصرحا ان هناك
30 كم على طول الحدود المشتركه
لكن وفق تجارب المنطقه تاتي التسويات بثمن
وباهظ احيانا مشروع التسويه الثلاثيه الذي
اقترحه الرئيس التركي قد يمر على جسرين
اساسيين القوات الكرديه شماليه سوريا التي
ترى ان من حقها حصد اثمان قتال داعش مع
القوات الامريكيه باداره ذاتيه تقيها ليس
فقط من الطموحات التركيه العابره للحدود
بل من عوده المحتمله لدمشق الى الحسكه
والتي قد تكون مكلفه عليها
جرون ثاني اوضحيه ثانيه الا وهي المعارضه
السوريه المقيمه في تركيا او ما تبقى منها
اذا عمر العربيه